This is Radiolab. I'm Robert Krulwich, boom, run and this anchor,
I'm going to curse you, dad.
I'm going to ask you to just simply do this fun thing.
You know that song that we both hate? [inaudible] um, pump, pump, Burnham, um,
pump. God. It's like the moment you start that and keep going.
[inaudible] there are some songs that I can stick in your head and they just
won't leave. There's somebody, of course,
who's a head who got this song somehow stuck in her head and then his songs that
just go away because you didn't even invite them and they stay.
This is an hour on the music in our heads. Where does the songs come from?
Why do they stay a whole hour without Suzanne Vega,
thankfully on radio lab. Let me ask you a question to get us started here.
When a song gets stuck in your head,
do you have one in there right now by any chance? Oliver,
the Broadway show tune of course. What does it sound like when it's in there?
What does it sound like? Yeah, but it just think before you answered six.
What does it really sound like? Describe it. Uh, musically. Um,
well it does. Well, it's funny that you mentioned this. It,
it's doesn't actually, I don't hear any musician because it loud. No,
it's nothing. It's not loud. It's not like a location, you know, tambor?
No, it just has a melody. A vague foggy. Like a shadow email. Yes,
exactly. Okay. Well, so that's our starting point. You know,
most of us get a song in our head. It's kind of like what you described vague,
but there are people who when they get songs stuck in their head,
it's a whole dish. It's a whole different experience.
It is not vague. In fact, they wish it were vague. They wish it were a shadow
and you'll know what I mean. In a second, let me introduce you to someone.
Mary had a little lamb, little lamb,
little lamb always has songs running through his head everywhere that Mary went,
the lamb was sure to go. He's plagued by them actually.
Then he spoke with our producer Lulu Miller and said that that was going through
your head just now. That's right. Mary heard a little loud over and over again.
Yeah. Let me have you just introduce yourself really quick. Oh, I'm a,
My name is Leo Rang Gail and I'm uh, not young.
I just had my 94th birthday.
I've been in la since I was in the War World War II. Leah is a psychoanalyst.
Oh yeah. I'm still in practice.
We find everything that's been going on in his own head sort of intriguing from
a professional standpoint. I'm trying to think what the hell am I doing? Anyway,
this whole thing started for him about 12 years ago.
He had just had major heart surgery and he wakes up in his hospital bed. Oh.
I wake up in the ICU and almost as soon as I'm conscious outside my hospital
window, I hear music and there was this,
it sounded few near-real like hymns. I hear these songs.
I look out the window. I've had a rabbi is out there.
I say to my kids, I casually say, hey, there's a,
there's a rabbi out this singing.
Yeah.
They said, what do you mean? So I said,
there must be as rabbi school and he must be teaching young people how to be
rabbis. And they, the kids looked at each other
the new
because they weren't hearing anything. But at that moment,
that didn't matter to Leo because the music was so loud and vivid to him.
So totally coming through that window that
I dismissed them as, oh well they could have their opinion if they want.
I didn't think anything of it.
Uh, Duh, Duh, Duh.
And then the rest of the week in the hospital, uh, you know,
I'm getting better and better and as I get better, the music changes.
I stopped being a Ma more perky and the songs,
the music out the window changes to Chattanooga, Choo Choo.
Did Dod do the chat, the new that you Chattanooga Choo Choo.
Did you Julie? One of the morning, two in the morning.
I'm waking up with these songs.
They're always coming in from right outside that window.
Then I thought, Gee, there's a pretty energetic group there across the street.
At this point.
Leo was beginning to suspect that something a little weird was going on,
but the real cool drug came when I was going to leave the hospital after a week
or so and um, this tune, I didn't know the words at first,
but I started to hear that that Duh,
Duh Duh Duh Duh Duh Duh Duh Duh Duh Duh Duh Duh Duh Duh Duh Duh Duh.
Because he packed up, signed out of the hospital and got into his car.
I was reflecting. That's when it hit him. I still was hearing the song.
The song was still coming from outside a window, but now the scenery was moving.
I thought it was related to the hospital until the thing across the street.
Here I am in the car listening to this. Oh,
and that's when the lyrics appeared. Find me.
The words come when Johnny [inaudible] home again or Ra ra,
he couldn't ignore it anymore. Not only was the song following him home,
it's like the song was about him. He was the Johnny. The girls will cheer,
marching home, coming home from the hospital.
I realized I am listening to me.
I am listening to me.
Okay. Is He really though?
I mean is he really listening to anything or is he just think he's hearing
something? Well, there's nothing out there for him to hear it from the inside.
Like is this brain actually hearing music? Ah,
well lucky for us.
There's a professor in England who had the exact same question. I called him up.
Hello.
Hi. Can I speak to professor Griffith please? Okay. Tim Griffith is his name.
He is a professor of cognitive neurology at New Castle University.
Here's what he did.
He took 35 people who are likely who claim to be hallucinating music. Yeah.
And he scanned their brains. Right? Simple experiment.
I just put people on a scantron and said, what are you hearing now?
What are you hearing now? When they told him, uh,
there, there,
I'm hearing music that that moment he would snap a picture of the rain. Right?
Then he took a different group of people who have no hallucinations,
played them real music,
music,
scan their brains. And then he compared the pictures
and if you look,
they looked virtually identical.
If you were to put those in front of me and say one's people hallucinating the
other people being played, music I, I wouldn't be able to tell you,
which was weird,
which tells you two things. First, this condition is real.
These people are not making it up, and second,
this goes way beyond the ordinary experience that the rest of us have where we
get a song stuck in our head.
These people are getting the full high Phi experience of listening to music.
Their entire brain is lit up.
The music sounds so convincingly like real life music.
What are you to think when it suddenly appears? That's Diana Deutsch,
a psychologist at the University of California,
San Diego who's been collecting emails from hundreds of different people who
hallucinate music. One person described it in the following way. He said,
imagine that you wear to a rock concert standing right by loudspeaker.
Well, it's louder than that.
At the beginning when I didn't know what was going to happen,
I thought it was going to take over my mind.
You hear that it started interfering with sleep. It's the Atchison,
Topeka and Santa Fe.
Ah,
well night. Oh, I got mad. I used to say, stop it already.
Stop it. Cut it out. Come on. Enough. Enough. Enough. But you're never free.
Yes. Never.
Yes. That was the low point. I thought, I've got to get help for this.
At what point did you bring it up with doctors? Oh, the doctors,
they were completely impotent. To this day. They rolled their eyes.
When I tell them about it,
one doctor told him that maybe it was the fillings in his teeth picking up the
radio. Okay. I hoped it was right, but it wasn't. It continued forever.
Nothing he could do. It could make it stop. I don't have an off button.
It's like there was a jukebox in his head run by an evil Gremlin.
In the worst part, the Gremlin would mess with the tempo. Like,
uh, okay. Uh, that are Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah,
Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah.
And have the man on the flying.
Drippy is letting young man only the flagging speeding up, Dah, Dah, Dah,
Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah.
That's the worst when that started to happen, I'm really getting close to panic.
I have the feeling that it could go at its rate and I couldn't stop.
It stands on my own.
It's like you're on a galloping horse and the horse runs away with you. Oh,
you guys do that. I once told that to my daughter. She said, dad,
why did you just instead think of the song?
No.
And I could control the tempo and instead when that galloping, I would
go,
uh, I did, uh, uh,
the
[inaudible]
an immediately up, completely relaxed as well.
And the Gallup is
completely gone and I couldn't even let it come
back. And it would start now being, Oh God,
yeah, Duh, Duh, Duh, Duh.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
and that was no longer ever a problem of the tempo running away with me.
Okay. So let's just assume Leo is not crazy.
I never thought I was psychotic. Never. Never. Because most people,
it turns out with this condition are not crazy.
There's nothing else wrong with them according to Diana Deutsch.
So then the question becomes,
how can a person who is otherwise sane hallucinate to such a crazy degree?
Well,
in the 60s there was a Polish psychologist named Jersey Konarski who thought
about this and uh,
and he came up with a simple kind of beautiful idea based on an assumption that
he couldn't prove yet, which was that between the ears and the brain,
there are some connections.
He thought just a few stray connections that run backwards brain back to ear,
which would allow sound to run in reverse. Now, this was just an idea.
He couldn't really test it, but many years later,
sure neuroscientists like Tim Griffith start to poke around in the brain.
They start to explore and what they find is that he was right.
Yes. Daily. Right. Do you look at the pathway between the years on the brain?
Probably about 70% of the fibers don't actually go up. They go down,
they go the other way. Towards the end,
70% go out. 70% go from the brain to the ears.
Yeah. It's like our ears are literally wired to hear our brains now.
Konarski his idea was that normally our ears wouldn't hear what the brain was
saying because it was too busy. You taking in all the sounds from the outside,
but what if he thought the sound from the outside stopped?
Maybe then there would be a kind of backflow
sound stored in your brain would start to flow backwards. Now again,
this is just an idea,
but there might be something to this because it would explain why most of the
people who suffer from musical hallucinations,
according to Tim Griffith have one thing in common
by far and away.
The common situation you see it in is in people who have deafness usually in
middle or later life
and you have to take his word for it. Nearly the incident that I went deaf,
I started experiencing round the clock,
24 seven auditory hallucinations.
This is Michael Cora's.
When he was 36 he lost all of his hearing and he remembers the moment that it
happened.
He was in the emergency room talking to a nurse and suddenly the sound started
to go.
It was like going from talking like this to talking like this to Tony like this,
to talk like this. My ears were just draining out like water draining of the,
uh, of about, uh,
I was just getting deffer and different deffer and at the same time I was dying
to hear
a very loud ringing sound in my ears.
It was gradually morphing prints of sort of formless eerie,
ethereal music, music at the spheres.
Really don't recall it. And you read slowly more
into some version of the Avi Maria
[inaudible].
It was almost as if as a sort of recompense to being deaf.
I was like plugged into some sort of deep background Meli and the cosmos.
Yeah. Here's the question.
What would happen if Michael suddenly got his hearing back? Well,
a couple of months later, Michael got a cochlear implant installed.
This is a little chip.
It's put into his brain which promise to return at least part of his hearing.
And he says when the doctor's turned it on
[inaudible]
moment, he says they turned it on, it sounds from the world came brushing
and the music stopped,
stopped cold. Just went away almost instantaneously.
Huh? There you go. Well,
but I happen to know a woman who had a very,
very different experience. What do you mean she had the same problem?
She went deaf. She started hearing music. Let's see. What kind of music was it?
Um, hands, spirituals, patriotic songs. Uh, her name, uh,
this is actually a real name. It's Cheryl sees what we're going to call her.
She wanted the music in her head to stop and she'd heard about a patient,
like your friend there who had musical hallucinations.
We saved the cochlear implant and her hallucinations disappeared.
So I wanted to do it. So she did it. She got the implants,
she wakes up on the operating table and I heard the music.
It was inside me still there. Just was there. I can't stop it.
Why in the first case, and they're, they're kind of the same situation.
They are very much the same. Why would there be that difference?
I don't know why there is this difference between them.
So I asked a Dr. Oliver Sacks, we often talk to on these questions.
How do you explain the difference as a physician who no one sees patients that
you, you ask about their symptoms, they produce their symptoms,
but it is equally important to see the relation of the symptoms of the disease
to the person themselves, to the identity.
He's discovered over the years that the problem is expressed in the patient is
partly a disease. I mean the person is sick or in trouble in some way.
At the same time the disease is reflecting something about the person in front
of him when sees interaction and a, a liaison,
a collusion, the condition,
I don't know what word to use between the self and a symptom and sometimes it
can come out. So strangely, for example,
there is a patient he has who was a Jewish guy. He was a Jewish boy who, who'd,
who'd grown up in Hamburg and the 1920 and 1930s and he had been terrified by
the Nazi youth and for some horrible reason he hallucinated Nazi marching songs.
He was tormented. But on the other hand,
Oliver told me about an old woman he wants made in a nursing home who was
haunted by lullabies one after the other nonstop. But see,
she was an orphan.
Father died before she was born and her mother before she was five orphaned
alone.
She found the songs in her head deeply comforting the music and the
hallucinations in fact seemed to be a door into a lost part of childhood.
So then the differences between people and music floods into their head.
What's going on says Oliver is the disease and the person they're talking to
each other, the, the self can be molded by hallucination,
but it can mold them in turn. I wonder where Leo fits into this. Lulu,
how would you say that that Leo self interacts with his symptoms or vice versa?
Well, uh, he's a psychoanalyst, so whenever he gets a song stuck in his head,
which is like all the time, he analyzes it,
he looks for a hidden meaning and [inaudible]
like, you know the way dreams reveal your inner life. The same thing with songs.
Leo will tell you that every song is a message from his subconscious.
Everything has an unconscious connection, pleasant or unpleasant,
and he's just got to figure out what it is.
I'm analyzing me like I have a patient in front of me.
Like when I first called him up, he had a,
Mary had a little lamb stuck in his head that he told me it was because he'd
been thinking about
passivity of the American people in following a leader that misleads them and
everywhere that Mary went, the lamb was, was sure to go. I'm in,
and the connection is obvious.
Or when he first got home from the hospital, he always had America.
The beautiful stuck in it,
and I'm certainly not a raving paper yet,
but what this meant was Holmes Weed America to me was home.
It's easy to think that this is kind of a stretch.
I mean every song has some very specific meaning for him,
but I dunno,
there was this one time he told me about where he woke up with a song in his
head.
I stopped going to brush my teeth. I'm singing along as I go to the bathroom.
This is what it was. It's just a few years after his wife had died.
My Bonnie lies over the ocean.
My Bernie lies over the sea.
My Bernie lies over the ocean, the Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah,
Dah. Bring back, bring back,
bring back my Bonnie to me. To me. Yeah.
And um,
I realized when I said, why am I singing that song?
And then suddenly I realized it was our wedding anniversary that week.
That was one of our major anniversaries. You know,
that song can kill me when I hit it.
Even. So he told me that when that song comes, he doesn't want it to go.
I found that when the song disappeared, I didn't want it to disappear.
It's now been over a decade of hallucinating music for Leo and he found that at
some point the music switched and went from intruder to friend,
Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah. Now he looks forward to
the Song Stars and Steel Guitars at the company to Dah, Dah, Dah.
Cause often the [inaudible] he finds himself alone that that the in Monterey.
It's true that one of the things about being 94 is that when you look at your
telephone address book, the half of them are not there anymore.
You scratch out the name and that's not easy. No, no, no.
Just Molly and me and baby makes three all happy and uh,
the Loo Heaven Radio Labs,
Lulu Miller. Thanks Louisville. Yeah, thanks to Leo.
Leo has a book out about living with musical hallucinations.
It's called music in the head, living at the brain mind border.
And so does Michael [inaudible]. He's the guy with the cochlear implant.
His book is called rebuilt my journey back to the hearing world.
You can find links to all of those on our website,
radiolab.org and I am special thanks to Oliver Sacks who basically gave us his
Rolodex and we were able to find all these people and interview them.
Thanks to LRA and Kate Edgar. Here's a system. Absolutely. Now Robert,
before we go to break, I just don't see it. One more clip if you don't mind.
[inaudible] couldn't figure out a place to put it.
From my interview with Diana Deutsch,
I was asking her about musical hallucinations and where this stuff comes from,
like where does the music come from, what triggers it?
And she told me basically, well, it can be anything. That's striking.
Example was somebody who wanted very much for her hallucinations to go and
suddenly they did go away and so she said, oh great,
this is the sound of silence. And immediately [inaudible]
the Song Sandra silence, darkness,
Simon and Garfunkel Song started, I come to talk with. So
the same Radiolab will continue in a moment
is funded in part by the outfits, p Sloan Salvation,
the corporation for public broadcasting and the National Science Foundation.
Radiolab is produced by W N Y C New York public radio and distributed by NPR
national public radio.
Hey, I'm Jad apple, I'm Ron [inaudible] and I'm Robert Krulwich Radiolab.
Our topic today is songs that get stuck in your head and won't unstick.
Now in the last section we would got,
we've talked about people who were invaded by music and couldn't get the music
out of their heads. Yep.
Now let's switch and talk about people who desire more than anything to get a
tune a melody into their heads. Oh No,
it was just specifically people who are professional songwriters.
Well like Pam. Hello,
my name is Bob Darrow and I'm visiting here with radio lab.
Is that it? And what is it? It's radio.
Everybody is completely aware of our program, but then again,
not everybody would be necessarily aware of Bob Duro was that good?
But you may know this. What's your
list?
Yes, I'm already up and I'm sitting here on campus.
Let's see. Whoa, my hero. How wonderful you are.
If you grew up in the 1970s and 1980s which I by the way did not new.
So everything that we've just heard I never heard before.
But you heard that your whole, Oh my God, am I heard? They go,
you know schoolhouse rock and you have Bob Durrow to thank for all the songs
that will not leave your head xe.
We invited Bob over to my apartment to sit by piano.
Talk a little bit about Hook Enos. That's right.
What makes a song so sticky? So sticky? For your head.
How does that happen? One ever gets there, but you get your,
he told us a story of getting a call.
This was back in 1972 from a fellow named David [inaudible]
call. He was in the advertising executive,
the president of a small advertising agency. And uh,
he simply said, my little boy, I can't memorize the times tables,
but he sings along with Jimmy Hendrickson,
the rolling stones and gets their words,
why can't we put the multiplication tables to music?
We'll call it multiplication rock. What do you think?
Looking at me and that shit. Yeah.
Did you say ea was confident? Well then I did some research.
I looked in the math books that I had in my library and then I just came to me
as your title three is a magic number. [inaudible] man.
Hey, it's good. Yes it is. It's a manager.
Want to hear Martin? Yeah.
Somewhere in the ancient mystic trinity.
And then I went to look in the Bible and I looked everywhere.
It is one of the magic numbers.
I thought of Buckminster Fuller wanting buck Fitz cause of that GTZ film thing.
Well, the triangle,
literally strongest shape that can be because it can't bend.
A square can sag, right and become parallelogram or something.
But a triangle is fixed by its very triangular parity, right?
Every tracking has three corners. Every tracking S3 side, no more,
no less.
You don't have to guess when it's three sees the magic.
I don't mean that's a bad number.
It's a magic. No. As you can hear from these remakes three really is a magic,
but in any case, at the end of the
the conversation I asked Bob drove the think back,
way back before you did schoolhouse rock, before you became a jazz musician,
back to when you were a kid.
Do you remember the first time you got a really good musical idea when a melody
that Kinda popped into your head? He said, of course I do.
Let me play it for you.
No.
The doorstep side by side on the doorstep brand
tonight. Shit. No. On the doorstep tonight.
We'll do the fourth step on the doorstep with my bread.
Okay. That's all there. That's all they are. Like that was your first song.
Not a bad melody.
Terrible words and I made it up plowing.
I was helping uncle John on the phone. I was riding a Herro.
I don't care where you were wrong. So right off the bat,
bomb bump on [inaudible].
That's a pretty good hook in [inaudible]. What I care about is weird.
Did that come from, from hearing pop music?
You pick up the phone even though one school I would say I knew something about
songs sub consciously form because it's a,
it's the architecture of all those other ones. Yeah.
Do these things like when you hit the right one, do they like shout?
I'm the one they do. They do. They do. I'm not gonna Forget it.
Now I can go to town and shop for groceries,
go to a movie and the next day it'll still be there because it identifies its
shelf almost kind of like it feels like it has. Suddenly it has weight,
like it has weight and identity in there. It is.
It's there.
Sometimes I get the melody and then it's just sheer labored and make the word
spit. Where does the melody come from? Melody comes the Muse.
You ever met this
use?
A lot of people are visited by the Muse and they don't recognize her.
When you were plowing that day way back, you know I had a muse. Yeah,
but did you know that you had one or do you just think it was just something
that like,
like your like new shoes and I thought it was something that just came out of
the air to me. I wonder if I stole it.
That would, that would worry me, I guess. Yeah. Yeah.
Oh that's one of the songwriters mean objectives.
When you think of a melody say,
am I stealing that? See the,
that's how mysterious this is.
You don't know whether the idea was yours as originally yours or whether you
heard it in some earlier part of your life and it belongs to someone else you
don't know. So the muse is a tricky kind of God is,
and you know where it really gets extra tricky.
Imagine if you write a tune and it has weight for you.
People begin to enjoy it where you live.
And then very mysteriously it begins to circle the world.
And people who don't share your language, don't share yours.
Tradition your culture. Share your tune.
That is really mysterious.
Ah, I got one for you. There is a delightful English artists,
England's property or young recording star,
but you look Clarke [inaudible] have a very fine
welcome. This is a tune that was written by a British guy who came in New York,
sang by a Parisian who everyone thought was American and what they made
everybody else. One of my favorite records to the car.
Listen to the music drama traffic in downtown.
And this particular record has special memories for me.
Bits of sweet memories if you like, because I mean,
I'll pull the record out of the case here. Um, there'll be, oh,
this is the original
well single that I would have bought at the time. High records,
no scratches. Always looked after a,
a clock downtown written by Tony Hatch.
I didn't write downtown specifically for Petula Clark.
Yeah,
well I'd been to New York in October,
1964 I stayed on central park, turned left from the [inaudible]
him
dad walk down Broadway. And by the time I got down to Times Square,
I thought it was strange that there wasn't a song called downtown.
When you're alone and life is making you lonely,
you can always go downtown.
Okay,
just listen to the music of the traffic in the city.
Linger on the sidewalk like a new on the signs of prison. How can you be
Bobby Stanley
[inaudible] sonic?
It had different meanings in different places,
but for me on that first trip there, it was the center of life.
It was a great place to be and even though I was on my own,
I didn't feel lonely. That's the first line of the song.
When you're low, none, life is making you lonely. You
can always go down.
I brought the idea back to the UK and in those days in between recording
sessions and mixing down the recording session,
I used to have about an hour in the recording studio and I would go and sit in
the studio and just a doodle around it. It's a good time.
After a three hour recording session,
the mind was very active and the music was flowing very freely.
I actually then wrote the tune to downtown. That was it. I left it.
Well, I remember when Tony Hatch came to the apartment in Paris.
That's where I was living at the time. You know, I had moved over to France.
I've married a Frenchman,
already had two small children and a life was great.
This was I guess in 63 or four and I said, well, I tell you what,
I'll go make a cup of tea and you play something to me on the piano.
[inaudible]
I played her the bones of downtown, the,
the outline of it and the few words that I had and put the word downtown into
wherever it was going to go.
And I was in the kitchen making tea when I first heard the music for downtown
and I absolutely adored it and I came back with a t and I said,
that's the one I wonder record.
That could be a fantastic song and a great record.
We were in the studio maybe a couple of weeks later and recorded a monster.
Okay. Now here's the interesting thing. As the song grew, something happened.
The meaning began to change a bit. I mean,
here's a song that was initially a celebration of the city. You go downtown,
you see the bright lights, you with people, you'll never be alone. Well,
after a while,
Petula Clark and some of the people who sang it expanded the song to include the
exact opposite, meaning instead of comforting,
the city is now a haunted place and you are now more alone than ever.
Same Song completely, right?
It's got a lot of character and a lot of different angles you could take on it.
The one that sprung to mind for us was the kind of blade runner,
like a much darker picture of what it's like to go downtown
[inaudible].
I always thought with the original that it presented a very happy,
bright lights thing that you always had this sense of shallowness that if you
were on your own and you went downtown,
it probably stay on your own and get quite depressed at sleep.
Watching lots of people having fun around you,
right? You resolve the noise.
Just being out on the street and being with other people and seeing the lights.
There's a kind of slight desperation in that life. How can,
the lights are much brighter there. You can forget all your troubles.
Forget all your care. I like that line. The lights are much brighter there.
You can forget all your troubles. Forget all your care while you can't actually,
but you can go out and try. It takes your mind off stuff.
Yeah.
Don't hang around and let your problems surrounding their movie shows.
Want to go downtown.
Maybe you know some little places to go to where they never close downtown.
[inaudible]
thank you to Ellen hole and the BBC and falling tree productions for that piece
you note. I think if our question right now is like,
when a song falls from Song Heaven, why does it find an audience?
Sometimes the global audience,
how I think it's not really the music in this case. I mean it's a catchy sure,
but the experience of going downtown in New York and you're excited,
you want to see the bright lights,
you want to be with people and you get there and it still sucks.
You still lonely. I think people in Shanghai understand that feeling.
People in Bombay, everybody knows that feeling.
Yeah. It's like migration music in a way. Yeah. You know,
moving from one place to a new place. Yeah.
And there is interestingly precedent for this 50 years before they wrote
downtown,
this was already happening on a much bigger scale than I had ever imagined.
Right here I learned about this from, from this Guy Aaron A. Fox.
He is a professor of musicology at Columbia University in New York and the damn
good country, Western league guitar player, country,
not that rock and roll one too deep down in narrow Nan and [inaudible].
I hear that train to come in Nitro and roundabout country music is a genre we
normally associate with Kentucky and Nashville,
West Virginia particular part of America will always pick up. Yeah.
But it has spread. He says to the most unusual places.
So some examples of that and there were quite a few include the uh,
extreme popularity of American country and Western music over the last 50 or 60
years with aboriginal Australians.
You mean Hank Williams would be recognizable to somebody similar in Western
Australia? Absolutely. Neely Dolly Parton being another one elite part.
Dolly Parton is this international global star of the world's music,
especially in southern Africa. She's a revere like a saint
[inaudible] Zimbabwe as well. Dolly Parton,
you can fill a venue with a band playing Dolly Parton song and everybody will
know all the words. Oh, his blood. Yes, doing good. He was in that rocky job.
Most universally evolved. Don Williams,
I left Oklahoma [inaudible].
If Don Williams were to go to Dar es Salaam or to Zanzibar or to Kenya or
someplace and book a club.
Don Williams has actually gone to Zimbabwe where he has filled a soccer stadium
with 40,000 people twice a row. Wow.
Imagine 40,000 Zimbabweans crammed into a peak state and down here in the center
in the lights is Don Williams.
I just wondered
what exactly are they hearing?
I have asked Grenadian St Lucians Trinidadians or Macon Norwegian bins during
the session. Chinese and American aboriginal Australia Anti [inaudible]. Um,
why do you like country music?
And the first answer is virtually always something along the lines of it's the
stories. Like as in the stories in the lyrics,
I was drunk the day my mom got out of prison and I went to pick her up in the
rain,
but before I could get to the station in my pickup truck,
she got run over by a damned old train.
That doesn't sound very aboriginal to me.
You know how many aborigines are actually run over by trains? Thousands.
Actually, that's not what Professor Fox is saying.
He says ignore the details and listen for the larger story,
which has to do with moving, with migration and with regret.
You're lonesome for something and the thing you're missing is the old hometown
now, the green, green grass of home, the green grass,
Aaron Foxes. You can boil much of this music down to just this feeling.
You look and look around me. You long for something simpler,
something that use that's left behind and I realize that I was only dreaming
what would be the best couple of examples you can think of of I missed the farm.
I missed the crickets. Oh, the start.
The first hit country song was in the style Jack Reverie for quote
little old log cabin.
The lane performed by Jimmy Rogers and Phil and John Carson.
The song was recorded in 1927 and that happens to be the moment if you look at
the u s census,
because he'll tell you when the United States crosses the threshold from more
than 50% agrarian and rural dwellers to more than 50% urban dwellers.
In other words, country music really exploded.
And this is not an accident when most people no longer lived in the country.
Country Music is born when the country becomes a nostalgic idea.
And so in America anyway,
suddenly there was this dreamscape of country places that no longer existed
except in heads. And the music started just been so.
People in Los Angeles had in Chicago, heard country in their minds,
it seems just as logical that people who move from the country to the city in
Asia,
in African Australia might have exactly the same experience that these songs are
sung in English. If these people in these far away places don't speak English,
what are they hearing? Well,
it's important to understand English and the real enthusiasts around the world
are English speakers. However,
one explanation for its popularity elsewhere is that even if you don't speak
English, the is literally in the music itself.
There is grammar here in the vocalization, the singers,
this is a very normal country western thing.
They actually make a croaky sound that is very distinctive. You know,
it's a gold [inaudible].
Well, I
[inaudible]
one of the principle vocal articulations is what country singers
call it cry, break [inaudible]
in my book by parts of the CRI break into dozens of different specific
articulation.
No, Eh,
and it's not just the voices by the way says Fox. It's, it's the instruments.
Instruments seem to be crying like the steel guitar is,
the signature is out of country because it's recognized as iconic of a crying
human voice. It's called the crying steel.
Uh, um,
you can hear the loons of them.
[inaudible]
and what seems to come rule is things just aren't what they were before and all
over the world where people are leaving from the country to the city and they
are an enormous number.
[inaudible]
this is a story. All kinds of people can understand.
Country is just as much Grenadian music as it is Kentucky music.
It's just as much a why in music editor as it is West Virginia music is that one
when you feel a football stadium with Dolly Parton listeners,
are we saying that they're there in part because the song she's seen are their
stories too? Yup. Yup. This is our music. Yep.
I've written a lot of songs about the smokey mountains where I grew up.
We had a good life back there in heels and we're all
going through some version of, you know, oh,
on one to two or 300 year change from being esentially peasants
to being modern.
I remember sitting know on the front porch on a summer afternoon in a skate to
plead against the wall.
Professor Fox has a book on this subject,
real country music and language in working class culture.
You can find more information about that on our website.
radiolab.org this is Casey calling from Fort Myers Beach, Florida.
Radiolab is supported in part by the National Science Foundation and by the
Alfred p Sloan down nation enhancing public understanding of science and
technology in the modern world.
More information about Sloan at www dot Sloan that org.
Hello, I'm Jad Abumrad. I am Robert Krulwich today on radio lab.
Our topic is the music in our heads. How does it get there?
Where does it come from and why? We want it to go away. Yes. No,
you think that the music you listen to is your music.
It comes from the place you live, but there is such a thing as everybody's,
and
we offer the next story as a kind of proof comes to us from reporter Gregory
Warren. Gregory wonder, you won a journalism fellowship and they said to you,
you could go anywhere in the whole world. Where did you decide to go?
So I went to Afghanistan. Have you ever been to a war zone before by any chance?
Yeah, I mean I've, no, but have you done any international reporting before?
Well, actually earlier that year I had been in Astonia covering and accordion
festival. So that was a, a prime piece of, uh,
so you play the accordion? I play accordion.
Do you like it an accomplished accordionist? No, no, no, no.
I'm just an amateur. Accordionist okay, but, but so when you go to Afghanistan,
do you bring your accordion with you? Yeah, I brought my car.
How does that work out? Well, I show up in Afghanistan,
I'm carrying my accordion and I'm thinking maybe this wasn't the smartest idea
because it wasn't an accordion playing crowd.
I mean I was coming down the street and women in Burkas are holding their babies
and little boys will actually sob, sob,
begging you to sort of buy a piece of gum.
Here I am with my shiny red accordion and it's just not very appropriate.
Does there come a time when you were actually willing to use the accordion?
Well, it was a weeknight and was in my living room.
I find that jeep is my fixer and translator. He's working for me.
He's lying on his back and he's flinging his legs up into the air.
A guard is catching his legs and flinging the back down. Well,
this is the kind of Ab crunchy, that's what we're listening to now. Yeah,
there he's throwing his legs up. [inaudible] pushed him back down, going up,
back down. So I figured I'd help him out.
So I start playing my accordion for him.
[inaudible]
and it's going well. The jeeps bopping his head too.
And then he kind of looks at me, this is it.
How do you know Afghan music? I say,
I'm not playing African music. And he says, yes, you are. I say, no, I'm not.
Yeah you are. I said, no, no, no, that,
that's like folks out from the 60s called. Those were the days my friend,
some song that my mom used to say,
oh, Dave's my friend. Yeah, that's my mom.
[inaudible] we'd sing him dance.
[inaudible]
no, no, that's an Afghanistan.
And then he's back to the app crutches and I'm like, no, no, no, wait, wait,
please tell me the story of those were the days, my friend.
So what's the story of a, those were the days my friends,
that's what we call it. Tell me about that song.
[inaudible] senior who is famous for it? [inaudible] it.
His name was Alma [inaudible] famous. Same Guy, Ghana son.
It's 25 years ago, but not [inaudible].
Then Paul showed them [inaudible]. Oh, that
[inaudible]
wait, wait, wait. That's not [inaudible]. Okay. It's true.
He did get it wrong, so I forgot about it.
I thought he was crazy and it kept happening.
I would bring my accordion played for some people. Every time people would say,
hey, isn't that an homage to your song? How do you say,
how do you spell this name? Z. A. H. I. R. I'm is He, who is he? Well,
that's what I wanted to find out.
So the first thing that jeep gave me was his entire CD collection and one night
I sit down, listen to it. I'm hearing one western riff after another gentleman,
Nat King Cole. Definitely a lot of Elvis. Like I realized I'm this tune.
[inaudible]
is the name of the year too. You can actually overlay the Elvis version.
No
[inaudible]
right on top of it. Is he stealing these tunes? Is that what you're saying?
It's more like he Afghanistan, like here's one of his biggest hits.
10 hoster them Denton
[inaudible]. Uh Huh.
Hey, you remember this is the song that the jeep sung to me,
but it did sound familiar. So I emailed this tune to an old friend in St Louis.
He immediately said, Oh yeah, that's that Western disco hit El beam boat.
Ah, that's a daisy. No, this is the western version.
It's the same melodies. Ahmed's a year version. Same Keven.
Now let's just go back to the almond. Say Your version for a second.
No, listen to this. My little [inaudible].
This is east meets West. Um, and say your style,
and this is like the mega hip in Cabo in 1973.
This the sound of Afghanistan
[inaudible]
so I begged the chief to tell me more, but this Ahmed's a yard guy.
And finally he says, okay,
I'll take you to meet the old childhood friend of the man himself.
So we drive up to this gate.
This guy with white hair opens the door low energy.
Chad forbid. [inaudible] said that dark, dark, dark, dark.
He's been friends with them since the fourth grade and he takes us inside.
He closes the gate behind us, the scene changes. Suddenly it's a garden.
Birds are chirping and then sit up stops and he points to this old fountain in
the courtyard and he says something in the jeep and the jeep starts laughing and
Najib says, you know,
this is the fountain where Ahmed Z ear used to play his accordia.
[inaudible] he plays accordion just like me saying that uh,
40 girls were lying down and he was playing the accordion here, you know,
40 girls, 40 girls. Oh they,
they did call him Casanova for a reason. But was that okay?
Cause in Afghanistan maybe girls and boys aren't supposed to like be hanging
out?
Yes and no because Afghanistan was a pretty different country in those days.
It's something I didn't even realize until I got there.
This is the seventies the women are wearing skirts and Jane Fonda haircuts.
The men are wearing sideburns and they're doing, they're James Dean.
And it's not just what people are wearing,
it's that there's this sense of possibility in there. The things are opening up.
Finally, and the poster boy for all this is Ahmed's ears.
He's a bad boy that I'm even [inaudible] taken. He had a concert,
you buddy all the places and girls would come to his concerts wearing new
clothes and not only all the girls have a fan of son,
but the foreign girls, they also were in love with him.
Let me just play you one little clip from one of his shows and I want you to
hear a little screen that comes right in right here.
[inaudible]
for young Africans at the time, especially young African women. Um, it's a year.
He was like, God, what does that accomplish? [inaudible] no,
mother will give birth a child as good as Amazon
and this is where the story gets a lot darker.
It's 1973 the Russians start to move in and the new president that they put in,
he doesn't really like them. It's that year at all. Why? Well,
it was really in their interest that Ahmed's a year would come out publicly
praising the government, and he always refused to do it. Anything political,
he wouldn't play the show. And some of his songs, especially the later songs,
started to actually have coded anti government lyrics in them. Oh yeah,
yeah.
And then he would have other lyrics about how freedom is the most important
thing. So what did the government do to him? They ban his songs from the radio.
They start throwing him in jail kind of regularly,
but even when he gets out of jail,
he refuses to play any of the communist party events.
But he plays plenty of his own shows. In fact, after one concert,
he meets this beautiful woman named for Hero. The way she tells the story,
he taps her on the shelter. He said,
he says, hi, can I talk to you? I turned my face. I said, yeah.
He said, no, never mind. He tapped you on the shoulder. And he said,
can I talk to you? And then he said, nevermind.
And he walked away and he just walked away.
That was pretty good seduction technique. But yeah,
I guess he was very good in it. You got lots of guys like that and he got hurt.
Yes, and they got married and she got pregnant. Meanwhile,
the political situation was getting worse and worse.
All his friends are fleeing the country. There are murders, tortures.
Somebody came to our house, knocked the door and he said,
can I talk to Ahmed Zeit please? Ms Aid offered them, can I get you a drink?
I said, no, no, no. I've just come from the Ministry of Interior.
There's a plan for you. I don't know what the going to do to you.
That's all I want to tell you to be careful. But
um, it's a year and his wife, they don't do anything. They don't,
they don't leave. Why? He says, oh, we'll go after the baby's born.
Five days later, it's his birthday. June 14th, 1979,
he's actually signing a contract for a concert that they went to sign a
contract. As he's driving away, he tells her to make some lunch.
When we come back, we'll go shopping and then I will
make Lasagna and then we'll go out.
So she makes Lasagna and she waits for him to come back and she waits and then
she falls asleep.
I had a very weird dream.
I'm somewhere very high in the mountains and I have no shoes and there is a very
strong wind blowing and my hair is everywhere. I know,
I see him, not the way he went in the morning,
his beard out,
like he hasn't shaved for the past two days and he has something white around
him and something is pulling him and he's calling me that I don't want to go.
And suddenly I woke up, I ran down, I saw my father in law.
He wouldn't talk, he was just bending.
No, like checking himself when bending and just holding my home.
I didn't know anything. What, what happened? So what happened then?
Well, the government says that, um, it's a year, had a traffic accident,
but everybody else tells me he was shot in the head,
probably by government operatives and the news spreads through all the
neighborhoods in town. So you have Tajiks, postions, Uzbeks.
They're all getting up and not really knowing what else to do.
They come walking to Ahmed's at your house.
The courtyard starts filling up with people. 5,000, 200.
They're inside the house. They're outside the house. They're on the street.
At this point, the body comes Bourne by six policemen on a stretcher.
People start to whale, they start to push. In fact,
all the windows break the doors break.
They bring the body through the courtyard into the living room and for Kiera
pushes through the police and she sees her husband's body on the stretcher.
So I thought he was hurt that something. And when I
pull the sheet from his face, that's when I fell down on top. Uh,
when I fell, it took me to the hospital and that's how Shabnam was bombed.
So
does she go into Labor cheat? She goes into Labor right there. Yeah.
And she almost dies in childbirth. Yeah. But her baby's saved.
She saved and her baby has the same birthday.
Then her baby was born on that very day. That very day.
[inaudible]
so then what happened? Well then the music basically stops.
It's that winter that the Russians and fade starts a long period of war.
You have the jihad, then the mood j Dean in the civil war.
When the Taliban come in, they just band music entirely.
I mean, no instruments.
We're talking 20 years where the cultural life of this country basically,
it's frozen. I can't even imagine what that's like.
I can barely go a day without hearing some tunes.
2001 the Americans come in Afghanistan's open, back up.
The radio is turned back on and it comes out of them.
[inaudible]
so Greg, when you turn on the radio today in Kabul,
do you hear I'm at Zaire or telling you it's my main way that I connect with
taxi drivers and variably they're listening to [inaudible] your song even now.
Oh yeah. Why? Because there's just not [inaudible]
been a chance for new artists to emerge or it's just, you know,
it was a deep freeze.
And also I would say he reminds everybody of what capital used to be.
I had this experience with my accordion again and again myself.
Even when I played people in my music,
they'd get this smile on their face as if I was reminding them of something they
knew before me. In fact,
there was one time I was up north and there was this big music festival and I
had brought my accordion and they said, well, why don't you play? And I said,
well, I mean I could play for you. Sure. And they said, how bout right now?
And so they kick the band is on their off. They send them to drink green tea.
They shoved me up on stage. I'm standing in front of 300 Afghans and these guys,
they're not from Cabo, they don't speak English,
they're not wearing suits and ties. This is a very Afghan crowd.
So I figure I should play some Johnny Cash. Okay.
Dolores
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
[inaudible]. It was the best crowd ever.
Greg Warner traveled to Afghanistan with support from an international reporting
project fellowship from the John Hopkins School of Advanced International
Studies. And if you visit our website,
radiolab.org you can see video,
actual video footage of that Johnny Cash concert.
It's worth checking out here each. He shot it.
So there you see them all in their strange non country Western clothing. Well,
we should, we're at it. We're at a time when you're on a website,
radiolab.org you can also send us an email radio lab@wnyc.org.
I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich. Thanks for listening.